foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on everybody Ian hardits
here on behalf of Pro Football Focus
welcome to another edition of BR fantasy
always trying to just hope you guys win
some fantasy championships why not great
day to be great as always before I get
into the show just want to go over some
key injury notes from an eventful
Thursday of NFL practices as always
David Montgomery is back to practice
with that ankle injury if you have
Khalil Herbert on that Squad I know he
gave us a lot of touches last week just
realize if Montgomery is back probably
will go back to Montgomery's where at a
minimum gonna make it a lot tougher for
Herbert to really get that fantasy
production we're looking for also Keenan
Allen still not practicing with that
hamstring injury I know Mike Williams is
a boomer bus wide receiver and we get
really annoyed when he busts but listen
to the first part of that phrase he does
boom as he has already two weeks this
year keep Mike Williams in fancy lamps
of all shapes and sizes about Keenan
Allen remains sideline also after shop
Bateman still not practicing with that
foot injury unfortunately gonna be tough
to get him ready for Sunday night if not
and you need a wide receiver Devin
Duvernay guys you keep scoring touchdown
he's about to have more targets than he
has all season if Bateman is ultimately
sidelined Kyle Pitts happy birthday man
sucks you have a hamstring injury he is
still not practicing unfortunately so I
know it's been a rough start in the
season for Kyle Pitts fantasy managers
you really do need to find a second plan
though because that now is back to back
practices where he has not been there to
start the week and finally just want to
note that with the Broncos running back
room right now latavius Murray is not
activated for Thursday Night Football it
was too quick of a turnaround with the
Saints coming off the London game and
then him obviously having to learn a
brand new system in Denver so NFL
network is reported that Melvin Gordon
is expected to be the Bell cow back for
that matchup we should still see plenty
of Mike Boone they also got Divino zigbo
out there potentially for more than just
uh special teams usage but overall
tonight and at least for week five
Melvin Gordon is someone that you can
fire up with a good level of confidence
as a top 24 option at the position now
if only we could have that 30th ranked
Broncos offense start looking a little
bit more like the group that we figured
they were going to be when Russell
Wilson know got sent there in the first
place find a few things before we get in
here guys Jameis Winston Michael Thomas
still not practicing with their
respective injuries Tyree kill added to
the ninja Report with the quad Jalen
waddle is actually back to practice so
that's a good news and finally in New
York while Kadarius Tony is not
practicing we did get Juan Dale Robinson
back so I know that entire Giants
receiving room has been a walking
graveyard this year maybe just maybe
Juan Dale Robinson can calm that storm
get us some good fantasy points there in
the future
all right everybody this is BR Fantasy
Live presented by State Farm thank you
for joining us I'm going to be your host
here Ian Hardison we have a fantastic
show ahead for you quarter season awards
now it used to be a lot smoother when
fantasy seasons were 16 weeks long and
we could do this after week four I know
we have 17 so we're working with a
little bit of percentages here but close
enough quarter season awards great day
to be great got a lot of good ones here
for you we got the MVP of course best
way for pickup Rookie of the Year
biggest bus breakout players and steal
of the draft so we've had these polls
rolling in the BR app all day long and
with that gonna pull up some of those
results and start talking about the MVP
candidates through four weeks of the
season so again fantasy football here
don't let me you know be pissing you off
too much and so far folks are still
picking the quarterback anyway Lamar
Jackson well over 40 percent of the
votes you know over at BR fantasy hey I
don't disagree look what Lamar's been
able to do this year the number one
overall quarterback after four weeks of
action then it's been a big tier when
you look at these quarterbacks and we've
all if you've played fantasy football
for a year you understand that you know
these Russian quarterbacks they have a
higher floor they have two different
ways of getting production of course the
Russian quarterbacks are going to be
able to be great fantasy assets that's
why running backs that catch passes are
as well and why Debo Samuel is doing
Deebo Samuel things but with Lamar
Jackson this year guys again the number
one overall quarterback take away all of
his rushing production compare Lamar
Jackson against every other quarterback
in the league purely by his passing
numbers he would still have the fifth
most fantasy points out the position so
when we have these quarterbacks like
Lamar like Jalen hurts like Josh Allen
combining their unique rushing ability
with now Sky High passing ability that's
as good as the other guys that can't run
that's where you get Lamar Jackson Josh
Allen and Jalen hurt scoring more
fantasy points than any other
quarterback through the first four weeks
of the Season our running back
nomination is none other than New York
Giants rusher saquon Barkley just a
fantastic start in the season after what
was truly the worst season of his career
last year at least in terms of being
able to stay healthy and not be
productive I coming down the stretch of
last season there's any Giants fans out
there you guys saw it saquon Barkley and
Devonte Booker you couldn't always tell
the difference with who had the ball and
that just was an indictment of saquon
having to play it through some pain not
being at his 100 best self oh he's back
guys after four weeks you take his
current Pace put it over 17 games the
dude is on Pace for 2
423 total yards now shout out to Nick
Chubb he still is the number one RB in
fantasy at this point in the season but
you look at the uses though saquon has
been getting more opportunities so the
saquon pick here both a hat tip two what
he's accomplished so far and the reality
that guys this is not going away soon
this has not been flukey for saquon
Barkley hopefully just the beginning of
an incredible season and finally at wide
receiver we do have the reigning
defending uh fantasy football MVP of the
world Cooper cop himself all off season
one to find the new Cooper Cup who's
going to be this year's Cooper cup guys
apparently it's Cooper cup because last
year in 2021 25.7 PPR points per game
this year 27 7.1 Cooper cup is the
highest scoring non-quarterback in Hall
of fantasy and he's been better than
everyone else at doing so so if you look
at the differences between the number
one quarterback and number one number
two quarterback and the same thing at
running back and wide receiver 12.6 more
fantasy points for Cooper cup than any
other wide receiver in the NFL just a
huge difference he already has three
weeks that's the top five wide receiver
absolutely incredible start for Cooper
cup after a whole another season of him
doing just that so before we get to the
winner can I get a drum roll please
it's Cooper cup I Gotta Give the Cooper
cup I respect your opinion chat I expect
your opinion I respect your opinion you
know be our fantasy Community but again
it's about that difference between
Cooper Cup and the next best wide
receiver Lamar has been incredible Josh
Allen has also been pretty damn
incredible and they are right there
within three points of each other Jalen
hurts also knew not too far behind so
your MVP after four weeks of the season
is gonna be Cooper cup for me right now
before we get over to best way for wire
pickup got a few questions in the chat
always appreciate you guys tuning in
with us from at J Bailey Heinz or Melvin
Gordon in a bind look man if you're in
full PPR I would go with name Heinz we
saw actually in the preseason for the
first time in heinz's career they gave
him almost every single first team rep
when Jonathan Taylor wasn't in the
picture I do think Phillip Lindsay is
going to be involved enough on early
downs but that's okay we want targets
not carries and fantasy football if you
know it's going to be a different stuff
obviously we want everything if possible
but Naim Heinz he has eight career games
where he's played over 50 of the snaps
averaging over six receptions in those
games so nine times for me just a little
bit of hell up just a little bit ahead
of Melvin Gordon but good job good job
by you staying active on that wave while
we're having those two options in the
first place from at Ryan r AJ Dylan or
Dave Montgomery if he's active I think
this would be a fair question if we had
completely healthy versions of both but
because Montgomery could be limited just
give me the shirt thing give me AJ Dylan
and honestly even if we did have you
know a shirt thing and David Montgomery
their touch projections are pretty
similar I mean credit to Matt leflore
and the Packers when he said in the
preseason you know he didn't think they
had you know a running back one a
running back too he said they're both
starting running backs that's exactly
what we've seen with AJ Dylan and Aaron
Jones so far
and from at Leo Rojas would I start Mike
Boone tonight not if I can help it again
I've seen all you rosters out there
sometimes there are going to be rosters
where it could warrant it but with this
backfield I do think it's going to be
mostly the Melvin Gordon show I believe
it was James Jesse or James Palmer with
the NFL Network he did report that
Melvin Gordon's expected to beat the
Bell caught back so he puts the ball in
the turf again you know that fumble
problem persists and maybe we do see
Mike Boone getting a chance but no I
would not go out of my way to get Mike
Boone and honestly if he picked up Mike
Boone and you're not going to use him
tonight like he's just going to be on
your bench you don't need them things
are not going to get better for Mike
Boone in future weeks and latavius
Murray is all of a sudden going to be in
the picture if you can drop Mike Boone
for either Jalen Warren the Steelers
backup running back or shop white
especially with shop white the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers backup running back you
really have a chance at getting a true
three down handcuff who if the injury
strikes their backfield they're not
going to be on your bench they're going
to be in that rb1 spot
all right guys next category up we have
our best waiver wire pickup once again
thank you to everyone out there that's
been voting throughout the day on the BR
app because it's been a pretty tight
race I mean you look at it earlier in
the year especially first four weeks
guys are coming out of nowhere and we
just didn't see a coming and how about
Jared Goff leading the way so far 37 of
the votes Curtis Samuel right behind
them Romeo Dobbs on the Romeo dubs on
the up and up if we did this again in
two or three weeks I wouldn't be
surprised if Romeo dubs continues to
close that Gap but let's start things
off with Jared Goff your overall qb5 in
the year 2022. just just Madness look
you guys are can't be can't be that
young you remember the Jared golf days
back all the way in 2017 2018 Sean McVay
came to LA and he was airing it out I
just didn't think we'll get back to this
especially not in a situation where a
Monroe Saint Brown's out DJ Chark is out
DeAndre Swift is out and all Jared Goff
did last week was participate in one
heck of a shootout against those Seattle
Seahawks so just really consistency
throughout the whole year I mean qb19
qv7 qb19 and qb2 the only quarterback
this year were four consecutive top 20
finishes
um that's not true actually Josh Allen
has got there but either way great job
by Jared Goff and literally this whole
Lions offense has been incredibly
fantasy friendly number one scoring
offense number 32 scoring defense it
sucks when that happens to you in
fantasy you're scoring all these points
and you keep getting the wrong matchup
but in real life and when you have the
players on that offense all it means is
more and more opportunities to score
fantasy points so qb5 so far Jared Goff
fantastic waiver wire option for anyone
that's been lucky enough to get him
takes us to our number two player though
which is going to be Curtis Samuel got
the wide receiver 10 and wide receiver
11 finishes and start the season he's
dropped off a little bit over the last
two weeks but guys we're still looking
at a top 13 fantasy wide receiver just
four weeks into the season and this is
an offense where we were really
expecting Curtis Samuel to be the number
three Target on his own team now you
look at the overall Target leaderboards
and guys Curtis Samuel 35 Targets on the
season that's tied for 12th among all
players with guys like AJ Brown and
Courtland Sutton yeah he's getting Dink
and dunks like his average Target theft
is only four yards when they want to go
downfield
they are not throwing the Curtis Samuel
they're throwing to Terry McLaurin and
Johan Dawson when he's healthy but you
guys have seen Carson once so if you put
footballs over the years I will take the
guy that involves Carson Wentz not
having to make that hard of a throw just
get it and Curtis Samuel's hands shout
out to uh Scott Turner that ocm
Washington continues to do a great job
featuring Curtis Samuel they've been
together ever since their days in
Carolina fantastic start for Kurt [ __ ]
and I think it's only going to get
better guys because you look at this
Washington offense most dropbacks in the
league so far Johann Dawson is going to
miss some time with a hamstring injury
all of a sudden Curtis Samuel and Terry
mccorm looking like Target hogs in an
offense that's going to have to keep
passing in order to make up for uh what
so far has been a pretty mediocre
defense and finally we do have Green Bay
Packers rookie wide receiver Romeo dubs
he's been on the cover of waiver wire
articles over these past few weeks and
for good reason he is finally getting
the chance to step up and be the number
one or number two receiver in Green Bay
whichever one you want to look at it
Alan Lazard has been there though over
these past two weeks and the answer to
the number one receiver in Green Bay in
that time has at least been Romeo dubs
so during that stretch wide receiver 9
and wide receiver 20 and PPR fantasy
points
could have been a lot bigger I mean this
dude had 24 targets over the last two
weeks and also led the team in routes if
you guys caught the end of that Packers
Patriots games Rogers doing absolute
Pearl down the sideline to dubs at the
end of regulation unfortunately could
not maintain possession of that
potential 40-yard touchdown all the way
through the ground Rogers went back
right back to him in overtime though so
expecting more and more big things for
Romeo dubs he's already the wide
receiver 30 so far I mean look back at
some of those other guys we were hyping
up you know in August uh Isaiah
pacheco's of the world and to actually
see Romeo dubs already capitalize on it
fantastic start the season for the day
three rookie in Green Bay but we can
only pick one and that's when the drum
roll comes in once again
I'm gonna go with Curtis Samuel here at
quarterback we know it's a position that
we can stream with uh she's someone that
really was on our radar you know still
in August because we kept getting those
great reports out of Green Bay again
Curtis Samuel is the wide receiver 13 so
far this season while he was being
expected to go and be the wide receiver
three in his own offense to start the
year so Curtis Samuel someone that
honestly we might just be scratching the
surface of his ability to play running
back too he's already got eight carries
on the season it's funny we spent the
entire offseason you know trying to
figure out who the next Debo Samuel is
going to be and it turns out at least in
terms of getting Rush attempts and a
bunch of targets and making a bunch of
plays and scoring a bunch of fantasy
points maybe this year's Devo Samuel has
the same last name in Curtis Samuel A
couple more questions until we get to
our Rookie of the Year from at Peter
needs a flex Brandon Cooks future Smith
Schuster Josh Reynolds ramandre or etn I
am leaning Brandon Cooks right now if we
can get Matt Jones in that New England
Patriots offense though and not the
Bailey zappy experience I would take
ramandre Stevenson finally in New
England it is down to a two running back
committees so Damon Harris still going
to be involved but hey we can live with
two running back committees in the year
2022 only so many workhorses truly left
that's why it gets three or four it gets
more complicated so Brandon Cooks if Mac
Jones is still out ramandre Stevenson
otherwise
from at Johnny longboard thoughts on CMC
going forward the CMC man 26 consecutive
games with at least 100 yards and or a
touchdown for Christian McCaffrey when
injuries haven't played a role into that
so look the entire point with CMC why I
ranked him number one you know over
Jonathan Taylor going to the Year this
is not a Victory lap plenty of smart
people also Rick Jonathan Taylor number
one if you had Taylor you had McCaffrey
you know pretty pretty uh bold case to
make for either of those guys I would
say but the thing with McCaffrey guys
has always been don't overrate our
ability to predict injuries because at
any given football play is pretty much a
car crash I was never going to fade 25
year old Christian McCaffrey basically
for a sprained ankle from last season so
McCaffrey I know the baker Mayfield
experience has not been good but we
still have seen Matt roll and Ben McAdoo
feature McCaffrey give him the ball as
many times as possible honestly if we do
end up getting it going from Baker to
Sam Donald I never thought I would say
this but that could even be a small
upgrade continue to fire up Christian
McCaffrey as the top three running back
that he has been this season and finally
at the lady daddy Naji or Damien Pierce
it's getting tougher and tougher with
Naji Harris guys I am still going to
give Naji the slight edge here because
unfortunately Damien just really isn't
going to have a chance to get too many
of the come from behind pass down looks
Rex burkhead's still out there getting a
bunch of targets still keeping Damien
Pierce as an early down back in an
offense that no I don't think is that
much better than Pittsburgh at this
point but to me Naji still has just a
little bit better role than Damien
Pierce I'm not convinced that Damien
Pierce is this otherworldly Talent
compared to Naji Harris albeit you know
the Rookie's been having some good
moments over these past two weeks
I've dropped Naji Harris a lot in the
rankings like he is much more of a mid
to low end rb2 these days still taking
him just a little bit ahead of Damien
Pierce though but guys let's go ahead
and get into our rookie of the year now
again thank you to everyone voting on
the BR app throughout the day we have
three very solid candidates already
emerging already putting up some really
big numbers to start and Chris olave is
getting the public support my goodness
65 of those for a Lobby those last two I
don't think anyone was over even 50 but
let's first start talking about Breece
Hall the New York Jets running back
because guys he started the season
behind Michael Carter it was annoying
you know we all drafted him in round
five or so like in a situation where it
would just wank of Michael Carter get
out of the way and he really didn't
until last week we did see Breece Hall
season High 67 snaps had 17 carries and
six targets and that Jets come from
behind when but even despite splitting
this backfield with Michael Carter even
having Joe Flacco in there for Zach
Wilson we've seen Breeze Hall work as
the rb23 the rb14 the rb14 and the r
rb16 during the first four weeks of this
season so again just the fact that he's
been having this sort of production
without a featured role might just be
you know the beginning of a major rookie
season for Breece Hall so one good way
to try to find running backs that are
undervalued and that could be popping
off in the near future look at the
difference between a player's expected
fantasy points and their real fantasy
points and this year only Joe Mixon and
saquon Barkley have more expected
fantasy points than Breeze Hall the pass
catching role has been fantastic for his
fantasy upside only going to see bigger
and better things moving forward for
Bruce Hall now let's go to the leader in
the clubhouse Chris olave from the Ohio
State University you know the big knock
in college was hey this guy only broke
about four tackles in his entire career
at Ohio State like is he going to be
able to go into New Orleans in a crowded
wide receiver room and just really be
the guy that he was drafted inside the
top 12 picks to be so far the answer has
been a resounding yes I mean Chris olave
James Winston under Center Andy Dalton
under Center hasn't mattered he has been
the best offensive player or four it
banged up Saints offense that really has
needed him to be this good this early
and so far he has so we talk a lot about
air yards and fantasy football and just
quickly you know all Air yards measure
or the amount of yardage that the ball
went from the quarterback's hand to the
Target whether it's caught or not so if
you know it's a 50-yard pass in the air
to Crystal lave and it's dropped that's
50 air yards and zero receiving yards if
he catches the pass and runs them for a
75-yard touchdown it's 58 yards and 75
receiving yards so this year Chris
salave leads the NFL with 677 air yards
nobody else is above even 600 so he's
getting more downfield opportunities
than any other wide receiver in the
league and guess what he's made good use
of a ton of those Ninth and total
receiving yards ahead of T Higgins ahead
of Jamar Chase ahead of CD lamb I'm not
trying to say anything bad about those
guys it's more so just the fact that
Chris olave is already putting up Elite
wide receiver numbers and the man has
only played Four professional football
games this week versus that bottom five
Miami Dolphins secondary that remains
all kinds of banged up look out for more
Chris and Lobby here in week five and
Beyond
another Buckeye receiver closes out our
top three Rookie of the Year candidates
Garrett Wilson another top 12 pick spent
all his time in Columbus right there
alongside Chris lave in that ever loaded
Buckeyes passing game and guys he went
into a crowded New York Jets offense and
he took over just as well wide receiver
20 on the season but it's just been more
so impressive watching Garrett Wilson if
you guys saw that Browns game in week
two where he scored the two touchdowns
like you saw exactly what we've been
saying throughout his entire career this
guy is impossible to cover with a mere
mortal at cornerback so one of the cool
things we can look at in the back end of
you know our endless PFF tools is a wide
receiver's success rate against man
coverage even on players where they
weren't given the ball nobody has a
higher success rate against single man
coverage than Garrett Wilson this year
at 54 for reference Alan Robinson 20 so
Garrett Wilson has been absolutely
incredible so far and getting Zach
Wilson under Center looking you know
having some highs to go with the lows
that we all know about last week if we
do get the best version of Zach Wilson
appearing before too long though
surprised if Garrett Wilson maybe even
Elijah Moore maybe even Corey Davis are
all able to eat but there can only be
one guy so give me that drum roll here
for the Rookie of the Year
I agree with you all it's Chris olave
come on the guy is a top 10 receiver in
receiving yours and he's played four
games sharing an offense with Michael
Thomas who's taking those touchdowns
Jarvis Landry was out there in week one
going for over 100 yards himself like
Crystal Lobby has the ninth most
receiving yards in the league and I
swear if Jameis Winston had you know
three or four better balls in there Andy
Dalton last week too Crystal Lobby could
honestly already have a top five total
so I know he's someone that not exactly
blowing you away with the ball in his
hands and everything but just having a
quarterback like Jameis out there when
he is healthy who can threaten a defense
to every area of the field again for
better and For Worse you know Chris
olave he's a player that quarterback
safeties always need to identify before
the snap again not expecting this
production to go anywhere Chris olave
weekly top 24 option at the position
here moving forward we got biggest bus
coming up next but I want to get to a
few more questions before that from
atchick the comedian izalave the next
Justin Jefferson so I think Justin
Jefferson is a more overall complete
receiver than a lobby but I think a
Lobby is just going to be what a lot of
teams are looking for in the future
which is just getting that field
stretcher that puts the fear into the
hearts of every single cornerback out
there because you watch a lot of what a
lot of what Lavi has done this year
the guy's a fantastic route Runner and
hey credit to me here I talked about
Chris lave this long and not even called
him smooth one time you know most people
it's like the third word out of their
mouth but he is that freaking smooth and
he is a great overall route Runner but
the biggest thing guys I mean even
though it didn't count like he ran that
4-2-240 or whatever it was called as
first we know he can fly Defenders know
he can fly him when he got James under
Center willing to throw it deep alave
just has these deep balls and comebacks
for days so wouldn't quite put him there
with Justin Jefferson honestly I think
Garrett Wilson is a better comp to
Justin Jefferson because I think both
those guys just man-to-man coverage are
complete nightmares for anyone to handle
with but I can see Chris olave being you
know more of a kind of modern version of
DeSean Jackson that field stretching
specialist who can do some other things
but why do you even need him to do other
things because you know being able to
run past a quarterback On Any Given play
awfully good deal to have there in your
offense
from at spicy sponge a lave or DK
Metcalf this week hey you got two of my
top 20 wide receivers right there so I
would like to say both but I can't look
at your roster unfortunately the big
thing for DK Metcalf guys the only
reason he fell as far as he did in
fantasy drafts was because of the
assumption that Gino Smith was going to
be one of the worst quarterbacks in the
league Geno Smith has been one of the
best quarterbacks in the league you can
look at his PFF passing grade his
quarterback rating his yards per attempt
pick a passing metric and it's going to
tell you that Geno Smith has been
fantastic so will that persist over the
course of the entire season I doubt it
but at a minimum we don't we no longer
need to view Geno Smith as his bottom
five quarterback who just can't lead
anything resembling a productive offense
both DK Metcalf and Tyler Lockett should
be in the majority of fantasy starting
lineups moving forward so yes give me DK
just a little bit over a Lobby
from at DC Daniel Cormier maybe are you
flexing uh Khalil Herbert this week or
no it just depends on David Montgomery
is back again Montgomery did return to
practice on Thursday he's still dealing
with the knee and Ankle injuries so if
you're desperate I do think Herbert like
if there was going to be a week to play
him alongside Dave Montgomery it'd be
the first one that Montgomery is back
you know anticipating the potential for
him to be limited there but when
Montgomery is back just remember as much
as this you know the two and two Chicago
Bears have surprised us a little bit
this still does remain anyone's idea of
a rather atrocious offense so I would
not be playing the rb2 on the Bears
unless the rb1 is out when you can
afford that
biggest bust of the Season not a good
not a good topic to be going through but
we all you know we all know what it is
and we got three guys unfortunately that
if you drafted them you are not feeling
too good right now so when you take a
look at the poll results I am not going
to be uh overly surprised to see one
running away with it and it is
unfortunately Kyle Pitts on his birthday
no less so sorry Kyle Pitts get healthy
man you know get that hamstring right go
prove these people wrong but it has been
a rough spell for Kyle Pitts so far
first half of week three guys talking
about Kyle Pitts here first four catches
82 yards in the first 30 minutes of week
three his other 14 quarters combined six
catches for 68 yards like it's gotten so
bad with Kyle Pitts we're not even
talking about the fact that his only
career touchdown happened in London like
the guy can't score in America we have
all accepted that as a fact we just want
a couple catches in yards for the number
four overall pick from last year's draft
Arthur Smith hey you know what they are
running the ball well but unfortunately
guys it's only one of two offenses in
the entire entire league running the
ball on more than 50 percent of their
plays as much as I would like to say
that you know you know it's going to be
a great stretch for Kyle Pitts coming
off ahead we don't really know even
Drake London hasn't been able to make
doing this offense lately because Marcus
Mariota last week completed seven total
passes so unfortunately with Kyle Pitts
now having to play banged up you aren't
going to need to look elsewhere on the
waiver wire for options this week if he
is not able to ultimately suit up
our other two main bus Rams wide
receiver Alan Robinson uh I mentioned
this that before guys but just a 20
success rate versus Man coverage The
League average is 30 and again Garrett
Wilson sitting on top of the throne at
54 so we saw Alan Robinson last year and
it was atrocious it was Justin Field's
fault and it was Matt naggy's fault how
could anyone ruin Allen Robinson this
year's version of Alan Robinson is
somehow even worse than what we saw last
season last season he was still you know
dealing with hamstring injuries and
different things of that sort so through
four games Alan Robinson just 17 targets
nine catches 95 yards and a touchdown
last year through four games he had 13
catches for 149 yards and a score
reminder the Rams paid him 46 and a half
million dollars to come here and be
their number two next to Cooper Cub just
hasn't been the case so far so wide
receiver 74 on the season right now Alan
Robinson is the Rams number three pass
game option behind Cooper cup and Tyler
higbee you hate to see that I also gotta
talk about forever DJ Moore been on this
list seemingly every single season of
his career not because it's his fault
just because these quarterbacks cannot
get him the ball and it has been worse
than ever with the baker Mayfield
experience under Center and Carolina
4.8 yards per Target for DJ Moore this
year guys I can't overstate how
horrendous that is last year it was not
pretty in Carolina we all saw what it
looked like with Sam darnold PJ Walker
and Lake career Cam Newton under Center
he averaged 7.1 yards per Target even
with that group so Panthers dead last in
the EPA per play dead last EPA per pass
play Baker Mayfield looks Shell Shocked
under Center I don't know if it's going
to get better for DJ Moore last week
should have been the week they threw him
11 targets after he only had six in the
first three games still hasn't cleared
50 receiving yards either once this
season so again with the DK Metcalf
thing you know we got that question
earlier when we had someone like Geno
Smith under center it's okay if Geno
isn't even a great quarterback he can be
a below average Quarterback and we can
still have good fantasy production you
just can't be the worst quarterback in
the entire league unfortunately like
Baker Mayfield has been to start the
season but there can only be one so
drama role please
happy birthday Kyle Pitts you are the
biggest bus of the first four weeks of
the Season again I really don't think
this one is totally on Kyle Pitts they
just haven't been giving him many
opportunities now as much as I want to
you know say Arthur Smith's an idiot and
this and that look last week they only
completed seven passes because they were
running the ball better than almost any
team we've seen in the league Drake
London's putting up big numbers I think
if anything we all maybe should have
taken a little bit of a step back you
know in the preseason side of things and
saying hey they did just draft the top
10 wide receiver Kyle Pitts do we really
want to take the potential number two
option in an offense about to be run by
Marcus Mariota in the third round at
least through four weeks it's looking
like the answer should have been no to
that a couple more questions from the
chat here at Eric barcelli Kittle or
Gerald Everett I'm still leading with uh
George Kittle here so some of that stuff
going crazy about you know kiddo being a
left tackle now guys he still ran around
85 percent of Jimmy garoppolo's
dropbacks last week so this isn't a
situation where kiddo's out there you
know completely blocking every single
time he was a good three inches away
from scoring touchdown last week
unfortunately just kidding couldn't get
that second foot down and Bounds in the
back of the end zone so Gerald Everett
like man there's only six or seven tight
ends where I would be answering with the
other guy when unless uh versus Sam
George Kittle is one of those guys
though
at boysenberry Matthew Stafford or Teddy
Bridgewater I'm gonna go with Stafford
here for another week I don't think I
can persist and continue to be this bad
at least we have seen Cooper cup keep on
keeping on throughout it but yes I mean
staff for this year three fantasy
finishes that's the qb29 or Worse
unfortunately with Teddy Bridgewater I
do wonder if we're going to see you know
more so of a run-first version of this
Dolphins offense in the absence of Tua
and unfortunately for Teddy Bridgewater
I'm not so sure he's gonna have the best
versions of tyreiko and Jalen waddle out
there Tyreke actually got added to the
injury report today with a quad injury
waddle just got back to practice today
as he continues to nurse that groin
injury so it's just a situation in Miami
where you know Cedric Wilson's been
banged up Mike to Sicky isn't on the
field if Tyreek Hill and Jalen waddle
aren't playing like the two best wide
receivers in the league I think it's
gonna be tough for Teddy or anyone else
for that matter uh to make things work
in this offense and finally at RC Italy
should I pick up Odell off the waiver
wire
you'd have to have an awfully deep
League I'm refreshing uh my Twitter feed
here make sure I didn't miss uh Odell
Beckham getting signed anywhere because
that would be absolutely crazy news
right now the best case scenario for
Odell Beckham Jr would be you know what
Von Miller's talking about about him
going to Buffalo for a team that needs
help out wide receiver the problem is
guys we just have no idea how far along
he is from a torn ACL that happened last
February like think about all those wide
receivers stuff Chris goblins of the
world who we just didn't know if they
were going to be able to make it back in
time for even week one obj has another
good two months past most of those guys
in terms of his recovery so Odell
Beckham I really think you're gonna have
you know bigger options that you're
going to want to take advantage of with
the bye weeks coming up right now I
would not pick up Odell off the wafer
wire but hey we're getting a little bit
of change of news don't be afraid to you
know go through a dark the guy a little
bit later in the off season
next category going to be our breakout
player of the first four weeks of the
Season got a lot of votes in on this one
already and I think we have a three
pretty good uh you know options here
running back wide receiver and
quarterback and Clyde Edward Solaire
Christian Kirk and Jalen hurts and so
far Joan hurts is getting the love and
you know it's really hard to disagree
with it just everything Philly's been
able to do on offense so so far has been
awfully impressive but let's start with
Clyde Edwards Solaire every fans you
know your favorite fantasy analysts
favorite uh sell High player because
even though Claudia was there just keep
scoring touchdowns no one refuses to act
I mean everyone refuses to actually call
him a great real-life running back as
well but guys he's been bawling and even
looking at you know some of the other
numbers that we use to say really nice
things about other players not name ceh
10th and yards after contact per attempt
literally right behind Nick Chubb he's
second in yards per outrun only behind
Austin Eckler so this isn't a situation
where Clyde has been bad and he's just
been getting lucky you know touchdowns
to make up for inefficiency elsewhere
he's been really good he just hasn't had
a ton of touches so he is the overall
rb4 on the season which is wild rb6 rb8
rb16 and rb9 finishes in the first four
weeks of the season in terms of expected
fantasy points use the rb20 so this
tells us that he's been over achieving
which yeah he's playing in an offense of
Patrick Mahomes and I think it makes
sense that he's over achieving to an
extent we still do have Jared McKinnon
and we still do have Isaiah Pacheco
getting involved but I'm not quite as
big of the sell high on Clyde over solar
guy as others because one I don't think
that you know he is someone that you can
necessarily sell high enough uh to get
you know that top 12 top uh top 12 wide
receiver top 12 running back that would
make you want to part with them in the
first place and again
this isn't someone with a workload that
tells us you should be unusable no I
would prefer to have someone that's the
rb4 with the workload of an rb4 but even
if Clyde's workload and if his floor
games are closer to a low end rb2 then
the upside rb1 he's been that's still
something that I think we can live with
on far more fantasy teams than not also
I'll give a shout out to the 72 million
dollar man Christian Kirk we all
screamed about the Jaguars overpaying
Kirk and Zade Jones and all these other
guys in this last offseason and guess
what okay they knew something Doug
Peterson and Trent bulky they knew
something that we didn't and so far last
week excluded this Jaguars pass again
does look pretty fantastic Trevor
Lawrence taking a step forward after a
disastrous Urban Meyer induced rookie
season but just quickly with Christian
Kirk 11th in yards per out Run ninth in
Euros for reception like if you guys
have got a chance to watch any Jaguars
games it's not flukey they are using him
as the slot Maven who is way too quick
in the underneath the areas of the field
for any linebackers and safeties to
handle you get those matchups you know
in zone coverage stuff and work just
massacres them and then they're also
still willing to use them downfield in
the same sort of role that he was very
successful with in Arizona so the
problems for Kirk in Arizona was just
that was a spread out offense I mean
we're seeing it right now really nobody
other than Marquis Brown is getting fed
in Arizona the last two years with
Christian Kirk he really couldn't get
get over DeAndre Hopkins in terms of
Colin Murray's pecking order so
Christian Kirk right now Undisputed
number one wide receiver in a jaguars
offense that's better than we expected
that's why he is the wide receiver 10
after four weeks of action in full PPR
scoring also finally Jalen hurts guys on
Pace for 234 Rush attempts this year I
cannot even begin to describe how just
crazy that is in the context of fantasy
football the NFL record is by Lamar
Jackson
176 so Jalen hurts is on Pace to
basically beat the number one all-time
rushing attempt season uh Pace by a
quarterback by almost 60 Rush attempts
pure Madness but guess what not just
what he's been doing remember last year
when the entire knock on Jalen hurts was
like oh he's just going to run or the
Eagles are going to get down he's gonna
score all of his points in the fourth
quarter now the Eagles have had a 14
point lead in every single or fourth
quarter they've been in their number two
offense overall in EPA per play their
number four offense in the EPA per pass
play these Eagles can do whatever they
want to teams on offense and so far they
haven't even met another offense that
can keep up enough for her to keep his
foot on the gas for an entire four
quarters so
fantastic start the season for Dylan
Hertz and we could honestly just be
scratching the surface here because once
we actually started getting some real
shootouts with these guys we're gonna
see Jalen hurts forced to do jail and
Hurst things over an entire 60 Minutes
of action scary thought for opposing
defenses so with that guys let's get our
drum roll
[Music]
I'm back with the chat Joan Hertz the
breakout player of 2022 so far I mean
really just someone such a great year
for Joan Hertz and a great story we've
seen all the quarterback movement
happening in recent years you know these
rookie quarterbacks that they don't you
know really show off in the first two or
three years it has been easier than ever
for these teams to go out and get a
veteran signal caller so if you would
have asked me in week one like what the
chances of Joan hurts being the Eagles
starting quarterback in 2023 were I
probably would have said you know a coin
flip of source remember this Eagles
offense in 2021 wanted to throw the ball
they couldn't throw the ball and they
had to become this successful but still
pretty gimmicky the most run-heavy team
in the second half of the Season
knowledge Hertz really bringing out the
best of everyone that offense including
himself so complete hat tip to Jalen
hurts in the Philadelphia Eagles one of
the best offenses if not the best
offense in the NFL at this point in time
from at Robert what do I do at Keenan
Allen uh cry man I'm sorry uh he hasn't
been practicing and hasn't gotten him
back to practice without a hamstring
injury still hopefully you have Mike
Williams Because unfortunately Guys
these other wide receivers in Los
Angeles they're getting the same room
we're used to as well DeAndre Carter
Josh Palmer they're all rotating right
now the only real sure things in Los
Angeles Mike Williams has a wide
receiver one awesome necklace the rb1
and Gerald Everett as the Titan one so
once Keenan's back once he's healthy
we'll be back throwing him the starting
lineups of all shapes and sizes but for
right now stay patient just try to
continue to maneuver that waiver wire
get that spot stutter in the meantime
from at risk is it time to punt on the
tight end position in drafts here's the
thing man like if you drafted Kyle Pitts
you're certainly feeling that way
meanwhile though Travis Kelsey is back
to being the overall Titan one Mark
Andrews has had far more highs and lows
this season but yes we have actually
seen some guys out there just putting
just their ADP completely to rest it is
funny when you see that you know top
five top 10 tight end lists after the 4
four weeks it's usually lettered with a
bunch of guys that you know we're not
being drafted in the top five top ten
but that's pretty common across years so
in general I do think that there was a
a certain tier of tight ends the guys
going in rounds five and six for example
you know you're Dalton Schultz's who
he's been hurt so I don't want to be too
hard on him but your Dalton Schultz is
your TJ hawkinsons of the world who yeah
we're gonna see some big weeks my
goodness we saw one last week for
Hawkinson but my big thing would be
draft your tight ends when the other
positions don't have screaming values so
that was the kind of Allure with Kyle
Pitts some of the players he was going
next to but clearly we uh you know had
that projection for pits just a little
bit out of whack so long story short it
depends I still think there will be a
handful of exceptions every single year
that warrant picks in the top two or
three rounds
all right guys final category for you
all thanks so much for tuning in to BR
fantasy we got the steal of the draft
again have had some voters going all day
long between running back Jamal Williams
for the lions running back James
Robinson for the Jaguars and won this
late round tight ends we were just
talking about Rams tight end Tyler Higby
so easy winner so far from you guys
James Robinson at 58 and you know I see
it but I will say gotta give some love
to Jamal Williams in the Detroit Lions
just one of the most fun players in the
NFL in general you know we all saw him
on Hard Knocks and what he's been able
to do so far he is literally tied guys
with Christian McCaffrey as the overall
PPR rb5 that's life as the goal line
back in the NFL's number one scoring
offense so the only negative I would say
for uh Jamal Williams this year is that
we did see last week even in a game with
DeAndre Swift out he only played 50 of
the offensive snaps so they are going to
keep Craig Reynolds they are going to
keep Justin Jackson involved in this
offense and unfortunately it's going to
be tough to move Jamal Williams too high
up in the rankings uh because of that
but still top 15 running back each and
every week Swift is out and he's looking
more and more like a top 25 top 30
running back even when Swift gets back
into the equation so again rb5 so far on
the season where is he drafted ADP rb49
pick 167 absolute steal in Jamal
Williams
gotta give some love to James Robinson
though Lord knows you guys have been
enough in that poll so far James
Robinson I mean we didn't know if he was
going to play this season coming off not
only an Achilles injury but an Achilles
injury that I believe occurred in
December of last year we saw what candy
makers look like we saw what Marlon Mack
looked like O.J Howard like the list
goes on and on of guys at a minimum not
looking the same in their first season
back from the Achilles nobody told James
Robinson that and accordingly he has
been fantastic the overall rb11 so far
and this isn't just one big game that
he's been able to put up a bunch of
points he actually has been the rb12 the
rb8 rb7 and rb61 so fantastic start from
James Robinson I do think that he
benefited mightily from you know these
positive game scripts Jaguar is really
blowing everyone out but when he
actually dig in a little bit further he
does have the clear lead over Travis etn
I do think we'll see James Robinson
continuing to give more rb2 weeks than
not here moving forward and finally we
got Tyler Higby look he's actually been
kind of unlucky this season as well as
that is to say but that's why from
Matthew Stafford is throwing you more
targets than any other tight end in the
league so just in terms again I keep
saying expected PPR points expected
fantasy points it's just based on their
usage not exactly what they're achieving
and Tyler Higby has more expected PPR
points than Travis Kelsey this season he
has more real life PPR points than all
but four other tight ends so your
overall tight end five so far he was
going as the tight end 16 when August
came around pick number 152 so this
season guys in terms of just
highest combined Target share from any
two teammates in the NFL it's Cooper cup
and Tyler Higby now I'm sure if I would
have told you guys before the season you
know hey Cooper company teammate are
going to be leading the NFL and combined
Target share you'd be moving Alan
Robinson up the boards but nope it's
been Tyler higbee's Tyler higby's world
we are all just living in it but again
there can only be one so drum roll
please
I'm going with Jamal Williams I respect
your opinion you know chat and the
voters out there but with that said
James Robinson ADP rb38 Jamal Williams
ADP rb49 through four weeks of the Year
Jamal Williams has been the rb5 James
Robinson the rb11 this is Jamal Williams
was drafted later he's been performing
better and with that steal of the draft
at least through four weeks for me is
going to be Detroit Lions running back
Jamal Williams
from at Ethan Lister do I trade JT and
JuJu for Kamara and Aaron Jones okay we
got some freaking trades going here if
you really are dying at running back
like you're looking at your backup
running backs that you're going to have
to start in the place of JT and it is
just brutal I don't hate this because I
don't think there's this you know
Newfound ceiling coming for Juju that we
haven't already seen already it's a
spread out Kansas City Chiefs offense
he's a fine wide receiver three and you
get the chance to basically swap an rb1
for two other rb1s at the wide receiver
three so I like that trade if you really
need help at running back if you are
like okay and you still have a couple
top 24 options in your own right then I
would be okay keeping the best player in
the trade which is Jonathan Taylor but
guys
that's the awards but we still got some
questions to ask this Thursday Night
Football on it's week five so let's jump
into personalized fantasy advice
presented by State Farm where the
personal price plan is all about
creating a price just for you and how
about the Thursday night football Colts
Broncos I know we got some running back
injuries going on but hey it's a
Thursday with football wasn't that long
ago before we didn't have that going on
so from at Elias Amari Cooper or Garrett
Wilson that is a very close one for me I
think both these guys moving forward can
be treated as you know just borderline
wide receiver three wide receiver two
type options unfortunately I just think
we're going to see these offenses hold
them back a little bit I do lean Amari
Cooper for now though for me Amari
Cooper he is number one in a passing
game that we still have a little bit of
questions about mostly volume induced
Garrett Wilson we still aren't positive
he's gonna be the number one with Zach
Wilson under Center don't shoot the
messenger guys Corey Davis leads the New
York Jets in the receiving yards right
now mainstream media won't talk about it
but Corey Davis right now your wide
receiver one with the Jets I don't get
it but that's life in the big city
what defensive matchup am I avoiding
this week so I have an article on
pff.com every Friday called the mismatch
Manifesto I take an offensive stat and I
just look at the defense instead make it
into one metric so instead of saying one
unit ranks X the other unit ranks y we
got one cool metric and just looking at
pressure guys Matthew Stafford and this
Ram's passing game I'm not so sure
they're going to have this big time
bounce back week so
I know I got a question earlier Matthew
Stafford versus Teddy Bridgewater and I
took Stafford there is a line with all
this but in terms of Matthew Stafford
you know having that top 12 top 15 even
bounce back week this is gonna be tough
against Michael Parsons and Company you
look at the Rams this year I'd argue the
biggest problem with this entire offense
has been the offensive line pff's single
lowest graded pass blocking group this
season so we have Alan Robinson not
getting open we have Cooper cup doing
his thing I'll be it a little bit less
efficiently than in the past I wouldn't
be surprised if Cooper rushing the
Cowboys you know at least cover that
four and a half point spread not a
minimum don't be afraid to bet that
under because I do not think we would
see either of these offenses having too
much success this Sunday
from at nasira start Russ or Jared Goff
I'm still gonna beat Team rush just a
little bit lost in that Broncos
performance last week was the fact that
this passing game looked pretty good so
I know that uh Jared Goff has looked
pretty good the entire season but let's
not forget that Seattle Seahawks defense
hardly a juggernaut that we were afraid
of so I think that was just you know the
perfect storm basically of a Detroit
Lions and Seattle Seahawks team both
having underrated offenses and both
having probably overrated defenses
coming together and having that shootout
for the Asians there in week four
from at hitle bench one between James
Robinson Naji Nixon and Josh Jacobs bro
what are you in a four Team league right
here out of that group I would actually
have to bench James Robinson uh just
because hey here's the problem with
James Robinson as we saw in week one as
we saw in week four he didn't just
straight up beat out Travis CTN like
James Robinson is the starting running
back and he is the lead rushing running
back but etn continues to play over
James Robinson when they fall behind and
when they get in password situations and
for good reason I mean this year guys
Travis CTN is right there with DeAndre
swept averaging the most yards per
reception among any running backs so I
think the Jaguars have two really good
running backs in their backfield
unfortunately in fantasy when they are
you know stretching things that then and
we have more of a 50 50 uh scheme than
any of those other running backs you
mentioned I am going to lean towards the
volume
from at dog pound Stafford or Cooper
Rush again like Cooper Rush Teddy
Bridgewater these guys just aren't quite
high enough in my rankings to get the
nod over Stafford so this is one of
those questions that I'm not a big fan
of I wish you didn't have to be between
Matthew Stafford and Cooper rush I will
be taking Matthew Stafford just by a
hair this week though from at Ryan Gilt
Martin Breece hall or James Robinson got
to go with Breece Hall maybe last week I
would have said James Robinson but again
we saw a mini briefs Hall Takeover in
that game last week season High 67
percent snaps he's continuing to get fed
Targets in this passing game even some
downfield stuff just couldn't quite haul
in that shot last week could be many
more big days ahead for Breeze Hall and
it's not like he hasn't been awesome
already again four top 24 finishes to
start the season even having Michael
Carter in there fantastic early season
start for the rookie
from App Michael would you start waddle
with Teddy starting or a Lobby for me
it's still waddle it is getting closer
but the problem with uh laves he's
probably got to deal with Andy Dalton
starting instead of Jameis Winston so
he's still got the touchdown last week
but guys that Dalton experience was
pretty rough out there there was a play
where Patrick Peterson thought he had
safety help safety had his eyes looking
elsewhere a Lobby could have should have
would have had a 42-yard house call
Dalton through the ball pretty much into
the stands in that London game so can't
quite go there when we do have you know
that big of a discrepancy between the
two players so guys that's gonna wrap up
another edition of BR fantasy have a
great week five we got bye weeks coming
in week six and we have another London
game this Sunday at 9 30 a.m so have a
great weekend but take five minutes on
Saturday set those fantasy lines before
Sunday morning so we don't have a
disaster like Alvin Kamara getting ruled
out while you're still sleeping again so
I mean hardest thanks again for tuning
in to BR fantasy and until next time
take care everybody
foreign
[Music]